agnès gardez vous êtes devant la caserne
des pompiers de fécamp alors quelle est
la situation ce matin yat-il encore
beaucoup d'interventions des pompiers
oui je me trouve exactement à la caserne
des pompiers de fécamp où
l'effervescence est un tout petit peu
retombée ce matin même si une centaine
d'hommes sont encore sur le pont il y a
plusieurs maisons sinistrées pour la
plupart il s'agit de caves de caves
inondées d'eau et de boue alors on
profite de l'accalmie ici pour terminer
ces travaux de nettoyage surtout on
veille aux installations et notamment à
ses bassins de rétention d'eau évoqué
tout à l'heure on sait qu'il se vide
lentement même si leur niveau est encore
est encore un peu inquiétant alors à
noter également que laurent fabius en
tant qu ancien député de seine maritime
a tenu à se rendre sur place a fait
quand c'était dans la matinée oui tout à
fait laurent fabius s'est rendu à fécamp
ce matin l'hélicoptère il est arrivé à
11h30
il était attendu pour les par les
autorités locales pour recouvrer le
point sur la situation
une très courte visite pendant laquelle
il s'est rendu à saint léonard cette
petite commune près de fécamp où un
employé communal est mort hier après
midi
pris dans une vague de boue il n'a pas
pu être secourus
une victime donc une victime de trop
prudents alors prudence absolue car des
orages pourraient encore éclaté en fin
d'après-midi tout le département de la
seine maritime en fait est en état d'
alerte jusqu'à ce soir au moins minuit
merci à niasse et nous en parlerons dans
quelques instants